manchmal habe ich wirklich den eindruck
dass wir nur die simulation erleben und
alles in wirklichkeit ganz anders ist
allein die quantenphysik mit
verschränkten teilchen und der
heisenbergsche unschärferelation ist
schon ziemlich schräg und verrückt und
fühlt sich so ein bisschen wie die
entdeckung des puppenspielers an wenn es
so ist dann haben forscher jetzt wieder
einen blick auf seine hände erhascht
super flüssiges helium verhält sich
nämlich sehr seltsam und zwar wie ein
schwarzes loch was es damit auf sich hat
jetzt entwicklung sei herzlich
willkommen fangen wir mal ganz einfach
an also wie in der feuerzangenbowle ich
habe einen liter kochendes wasser mit
einer temperatur von 100 grad celsius
den gebe ich ihnen einen liter eis
wasser null grad fällt wird gut eis
hatten anderen volumen ist dürfte also
de facto etwas weniger als in lila welt
aber schwamm drüber
nach adam riese müssten die zweiliter
dann eine temperatur von 50 grad celsius
halten die temperatur hat sich
proportional zum volumen geändert in der
physik wird wärme ja als entropie
bezeichnet oder besser als in ordnung
weil zb im gegensatz zu eins die
position der atome nicht mehr festgelegt
ist es wird auch als maß für die
unkenntnis des automaten zustand
bezeichnet diese entropie das erleben
wir täglich bei allem möglichen ist
untrennbar mit dem raum verknüpfte ich
die wohnung ändert sich die temperatur
mit dem volumen der 1 stunde luft ändere
ich den wasserzufluss des heißen wassers
in der dusche ändert sich die temperatur
auch mit dem volumen
wir würden geklopft werden der bande in
schwarzen löchern passiert aber etwas
anderes das mag der entropie ändert sich
nicht mit dem volumen sondern mit der
oberfläche des ereignet viel langsamer
bei unserem wasser experiment wäre das
etwas seltsam die zwei liter würden
nicht 50 kartell durchfahren werden
sondern lediglich 37,7 grad celsius
das wäre schon etwas seltsam aber
genauso ist es bei super flüssigem
helium 4 an der university of waterloo
in kanada simulierte ein wissenschaftler
team um den physiker christoph hartmann
das isotop helium 4 bei temperaturen
nahe dem absoluten nullpunkt das helium
wurde super flüssig die atome nehmen
einen gemeinsamen quantenzustand an das
ist genauso wie beim bose einstein
kondensat das erst im januar erstmal im
weltraum hergestellt werden konnte oder
bei der st
der gemeinsame quantenzustand bedeutet
dass die einzelnen atome verschwunden
sind das ganze verhält sich wie ein
einziges riesiges atom dem
computermodell sahen sich die forscher
jetzt die verschränkung der atome und
die entropie innerhalb imaginärer
unterschiedlich große kugel fan an und
wir da das verrückte wurde entdeckt die
entropie verhilft nicht genauso wie in
schwarzen löchern nachdem flächen
gesetzt es ist ein wichtiger schritt das
universum fotografisch zu interpretieren
dann wären alle informationen nicht hier
im dreidimensionalen raum sondern auf
der oberfläche sprich auf der außenhülle
des universums mehr existieren
eigentlich gar nicht hier sondern die
faktor auf der auslöser oder universum
selbst würde dich wie ein schwarzes loch
verhalten und wäre vielleicht 1 auf
diese weise erhoffen sich die
wissenschaftler endlich quantenphysik
und relativitätstheorie
zusammenzubekommen am thermometer im
innenhof in den usa will der seit ende
august bei der suche nach dem beweis für
das holografische universum so forscht
wir sind extrem gespannt was wäre wenn
das universum ein schwarzes loch wäre
ein wildes gedankenexperiment dazu bitte
hier einfach draufklicken und kein video
verpasst ihr mehr wenn er dir ein abo
aufs auge drückt ab jetzt drauf klicken
und dann habt ihr auch die chance mir
einen auf die glocke zu geben
aber das liegt ja selbst ansonsten bis
dann bleibt noch